hello everyone and welcome back to round
seven of defeated world rabid
championship it's Alexander Rachmaninoff
vs. Magnus Carlsen knocked on Ovie's a
Russian Grand Master some 22nd or 23rd
highest-rated Russian Grand Master but
as well not a lot of things are known
about him a periodical mentioned during
the live coverage that he's he's very
strong physically and that he's not
afraid to go into complications that he
met him in person and one of the things
that he's known for is that he always
avoids a main line so now I'm very
interested to see what happens here so
without further ado let's check it out
and also if you haven't done so already
do be a part of the subscribers video
send some of your best photos of you
teaching someone chess to the email
provided in the description below that
being said let's check out this very
nice game from round seven of the feeder
world rapid championship rahman irr
opens with c4 the English opening this
on the board with E 5 Knight to f3
knight c6 by Magnus and d4c captures
with Knight captures and Knight to f6
we have Knight captures and c6 b
captures and now g3 now putting the
light square bishop to this a very
strong diagonal we have g6 by magnus and
magnus preparing to fianchetto his dark
square Bishop Bishop g2 Bishop to g7 and
now Knight to c3 all right we have
castles by Magnus castles by Rahman oh
and not rook to b8 getting the rook away
from this nasty diagonal and also just
putting it under nice a semi-open b file
and here
quinta a for this game was already
played by Rahman of himself and he was
able to well he was able to trick his
opponent into going to a lesser line the
game ended in a draw but we're gonna
mention that fairly soon
the a7 point is under attack Magnus
defender would a sex the bishop now
nicely defends it
we have c5 slightly stifling a
development of course and spawns if you
put upon all the way then you can just
go see captures on d6 Ambus on we have
Queen to e7 now attacking the c5 point
and here Queen to a5 defending the pawn
but also pressuring the c7 for now
here now like I mentioned there is one
game where nights that I ate was played
also by Alexander Rahman of he had the
white piece he's upon play night to eat
and then game ended in a draw the best
continuation here is d5 point being that
after C captors and C captures you will
capture and c6 Bishop captures but now
you have d5 and now it's a very hard for
white to do a lot more you could capture
this but then the the eat upon hangs
also after the knight moves the bishop
and rook will be attacking the b2 bone
so this is a considered best for black
but it was never played before
here a cross and goes for Knight to d5
instead it's again a pawn sacrifice but
he gains a lot of activity for his phone
so we have Knight captures on d5 we have
C captors on d5 and now Queen captures
on c7 grabbing that pawn but now Carlson
is able to to gain a lot of activity for
the sacrificed pawn Bishop to e5 would
an attack on the Queen Queen back to a5
and now rook to b5 so he will be able to
pick the c5 pawn up whenever he pleases
we have Queen back to a3 and now just
developing leadership to b7 you can
always capture this guy white is unable
to put b4 since the rook would hang on
a1 so look the b1 now with ideas of
pushing before but Carlsen first grabs
the point doesn't allow it to be
protected so just Queen captures with
Queen captures rook captures and not
rook to d1 putting the rocker under nice
D file we have rook to b8 with with
pressure on on the b-pawn Bishop to e3
attacking the rook but now Magnus just
gets rid of his ass deep on with d4
bishop characters on d4 Bishop captures
rook captures Bishop captures and g2
King captures and do not rook the c2
going after the b2 bond we have rook
captures on b7 rugby captures on b2
rook captures rook captures and now a 3
and here Magnus goes for rook to a 2 if
ruk to b3 it's a pretty much the same
just the rook here and
well you cannot trade phones since since
you're down upon so instead we have
looked a to now Magnus goes for the a3
pawn rook to e3 defending and the now
rook captures on e2 and here we have
rook the b6 going after the a6 bone so
here I'm very interested in what you
would play here for so feel free to
pause the video and try it I'm just
interested what you would play here with
black well I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it to do anything
congratulations on finding the most
reasonable move to play here rook the e6
seems the most reasonable because after
captures captures its it's just the
equal material on the board and well
there's just nothing wrong with this
however Magnus goes for rook to be 2
instead he allows white to capture the
a6 pawn and I I have no good explanation
on why this happened either that or this
position after rook to e6 captures
captures perhaps perhaps this is not
known but I don't think so i mean it's
it's too simple of a position at the
engines would would say it was a known
tricky position or something like that
so really really really just a weird
we're the decision that rook the e6
wasn't played but okay Carlson goes for
rook to be do and allows rook captures
an a6 so this is still still a
theoretical draw but now white is up
upon and Magnus has the defense so he
goes rugby 3 and now G for not allowing
white black to create some room for his
King good h5 so h5 instead right away gk
% h5 g captures and not h4 so Rahman off
still up upon kink the g7 and not f3 so
although this is a known non wrong
position nachman of will try to push for
more than a drop as a why shouldn't he
he is up upon
that's why III thought the title was
fitting during the Magnus against Magnus
himself with f6
King to g3 into g6 and now kink the f4
not allowing the
Crossin to hide his King behind behind
the pawn
as once you put this point all the way
to a7 you are hoping to deliver a check
with the rook and then just promote your
point to a queen so the king has to hide
behind the point we have looked the c3
and here a Rockman of has one minute on
the clock Carlson has seven minutes on
the clock so but you do have a ten
second increment in this tournament with
a four
Eric on opening his pawn rook the c4
which king g3 and rogue back to be four
with a five now look to a for Magnus
opposed to the room behind the past pawn
rook the a8 and now came to f5 now
Carlson is cousins King is safely hiding
behind the pawn so even if the rook pawn
was here you wouldn't have a good good
way to push it all the way we have
looked the h8 hoping for real characters
on a5 then you play a rock address here
and you win the rook of course but
cousin of course just pushes the King
back in g6 we look back to a eight
defending the pass pawn and now came
back to f5 with 86 rook to a2 now and a7
we have rook to a3 and now rook to h8
now cousin has to pick up the a7 pawn
and give up the h5 point otherwise the
pawn Queens so rook captures on a 7 we
have rook captures an h5 with check came
to g6 attacking the rook and now rook
back to b5 rook to a 1 now Carlson will
use his rook to harass the white king
from behind with h5 check king h6 and
now look the f5 hoping to trade this one
for this point although that's also a
draw the story not a nut rude rook to b6
rook to fi first attacking the pawn this
way King to g7 defending and now f4 with
rook the g1 check by Magnus king gage 3
and now King to h6 with rook to d5 and
now King back to G 7 we have King to h4
came back to h6 and not rip the d6
attacking the pawn and now crossing goes
for rook to h1 check with King to g4 and
here rook captures on h5 with rook
captures on f6 with check forcing the
king away from the defense of the h4
group but also into the attack of the f6
rook
King characters on h5 King captors on f6
and now it's a king opponent game where
Rahman of is up upon but it is of course
a draw and here instead of defending the
pawn or knock one of just gives gives it
the caution as it would be pointless to
play with King captures on f5 and it we
have the best possible draw that exists
it is the draw by insufficient material
so it means that there was a fight and
the draw was you know very well earned
by both players just in case some of you
don't know this
instead of pushing a5 if y defends it
with the g4 of course all of you know
the only move that draws here for black
you know I I'm even gonna give you a
couple of seconds just in case there are
beginners here who have not studied the
endgame yet I would hate this to hear
someone studied openings before studying
the endgame nobody I'm just gonna go and
congratulate everyone for finding king
g6 of course this is the only move that
draws you have to gain opposition and
then prevent a white front from getting
the King in front of the pawn any other
move other than King g6 getting the
opposition will will lose so just
thought thought you you should know this
and if you didn't know this then you
should grab any book on endgames and you
know go through it it will do wonders
for your rate for your game in general
Nadia of course both cost and Rahman all
know this so just give cost on the phone
and we have a nice draw by insufficient
material so there you have it I do hope
you enjoyed it and seems that a
periodical was right about Rahman of he
avoids main lines and he was able to get
Carlsen in a position that he well he
was never worse he was always better
here and well if you're playing against
Magnus does really matter if you have
the white pieces you you're always happy
with a draw especially in such a such a
tough tournament so I would like to
thank Leon and Mark Seager aleisea
pitaka a Simon Sevilla shield floods in
the jewel in your subs a day for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video serum
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Vita world rapid championship for the
next few days so thank you I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day